- You've seen me play
"Surgeon Simulator" before,
but you asked for it in VR.
Let's play?
Peewoop!
Okay.
Oh, whoa, I just started.
(phone ringing)
There's a ringing phone.
I'm going to go ahead and pick that up.
- Congratulations.
- Okay.
- You've won a holiday for
two to Pyongyang, North Korea.
- Oh, I don't wanna go to North Korea.
- Please enter your credit
card details now to claim your-
- No, this just sounds like spam.
All right, looks like there's
a heart transplant surgery
that I need to do on patient named Bob.
I will say this is pretty
realistic for a medical thing,
except that water bottle
is not excusable in here.
No!
What is this?
What is this-
Diazepam?
You can't have controlled substances here.
Ooh, okay.
We have a patient.
We have tools.
There's a lot of blood on the walls.
Do I have guidance as to
what I'm supposed to do?
Nope.
I'm grabbing the saw,
and I'm gonna start
cutting gently this area,
because clearly we need
to take out a heart.
Why is he bleeding?
Chill, chill with the bleeding.
And why am I not wearing gloves?
Yeah.
Where's my assistant too?
Let's go ahead and put that down.
Let's go ahead and grab.
Oh, I forgot this.
You always forget the last rib.
These aren't even anatomically
correct ribs by the way.
Okay.
Usually we have like a
container for the ribs.
Just gonna go ahead and rest that.
Let go.
No, no, no, let go.
The heart is beating,
the stomach is there,
the esophagus is there,
the lungs are there,
the liver is just chilling.
There's pieces of ribs
that we're gonna need to reattach after.
The patient is losing blood,
but we have some blood here.
Can I reach for this or no?
Oh yeah, we-
Oh.
Nope, doesn't look like
I can reach for that.
Do we wanna record this?
Let's record this.
Yo, we vloggin' the surgery right now.
My patient Bob is doing really well.
We're gonna get the heart out.
Please like and subscribe.
Okay, we got that.
Let's see if I can do just-
Oh, you can just take out his lung!
His lungs aren't even attached!
This is a pretty realistic lung though.
Okay, whoa.
That heart is blue.
That's not a good sign.
We're gonna have to make
some incisions there.
What's the best way to make-
How do you turn off this saw?
(relaxing music)
I don't know.
Okay.
My guy is just, look at this.
My scalpel is just floating on one finger.
Okay, I'm gonna have to cut it like this.
Obviously there's a lot of bleeding.
I'm cutting a heart.
Let's just get rid of this esophagus
'cause this esophagus is bothering me.
Oh, I got the esophagus.
Gonna go ahead and rest
the esophagus right here.
I cut the aorta, which is not good
'cause my patient's bleeding out.
I need to get my scalpel again.
Okay.
Looks like we got the heart nice and cut.
Let's go ahead and get rid of that heart.
Where's your other heart?
Is it in here?
Wait, I need another heart.
He's dying!
Is there no heart?
There's gotta be a heart.
He died.
(audience hollering)
And it was going so well.
Brutal murder achieved
in a mere few seconds.
But wait, where's the-
Oh, was it in here?
(melancholy music)
Dang.
Okay, hold on.
Gimme another chance.
Let me just check if this
is where the heart is.
Whoa, shit!
Yo, my bad, bro.
I dropped your heart, Bob.
Let's just go ahead and-
See, if I put it in there,
that's gonna be a problem to get it out,
so you wanna keep it nice
and slushy right here.
All right, this is taking way too long.
I'm gonna use the
oscillating bone saw here,
which by the way, if you hit
a patient with a bone saw
on their skin, it doesn't
actually cut them,
because it just moves very rapidly,
it doesn't actually spin, it vibrates,
so it shouldn't technically
cut anything else,
so this is the safest thing
we can use to cut these bones.
Oh.
See, that was misinformation right there.
Whoa, it's like...
You think I could juggle this?
Oh, shit.
I wonder if I can get sued for this.
Let's cut all the aorta.
Okay, we got the heart loose.
We need to act quickly here.
Let's replace this broken
heart with the good heart.
Oh!
Look at all the balloons in my room.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Oh, you can't kick them?
Ready?
Dunk on the patient.
Next mission.
Let's learn about our patient today.
We don't know age, needs
a kidney transplant,
high risk for blood loss.
We'll just practice writing.
Take two
and call
me
in AM.
(phone ringing)
Let's go ahead and sign this up.
Oh, we got a phone call.
Yes?
Oh, I picked up the whole phone.
Hello?
Medical office.
Okay, they don't care.
Okay.
We have a patient whose
intestines are exposed.
We have the large intestines,
small intestine, stomach,
liver, lower rib cage.
The patient has one toe larger
and longer than the rest.
That is not the big toe.
Let's see how our patient's doing.
Sir, you okay?
Okay, we got him knocked out.
Let's do a little vlog.
Yo, we here with Bob.
Bob messed up his heart.
Now we need to get Bob's kidney,
so we are about to get Bob's kidney.
Please like and subscribe.
What up, what up.
Oh, I don't even know what the saw is for.
But basically I'm gonna
go ahead and insert this
right above rectum.
It's definitely very bloody.
Let me use two hands here.
The large intestine refuses to be cut.
My patient's bleeding out.
Why does it feel like the
large intestine is like metal?
What even is this?
A light saber?
Oh!
It's a
electrocautery tool?
Oh, no, my patient's
bleeding out pretty bad.
Let's cauterize that.
Maybe I need to give him some of this.
How do you give syringes?
Give it to him in his face maybe.
In his neck.
Does that help?
Oh.
No, he's bleeding a lot with that.
That's a blood thinner.
Oh, I gave him the wrong one.
Brutal murder achieved.
Okay, I need to restart this one.
Anytime you have a sharp in the field,
you wanna be gentle.
I say that as I'm cutting
through all of his organs.
Oh, he's bleeding bad.
Okay, I'm gonna go ahead
and hold onto that liver.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, what am I looking at?
Why is there a video of me?
Is it the stupid camera?
Quick.
God, there's so much,
so much intestine here.
Oh, I dropped some.
Stomach, you just will
hang out right here.
Oh.
Okay, one kidney, two kidneys.
Where is the kidneys though?
Oh, here.
Oh!
One kidney in.
No!
God.
(audience hollering)
My back hurts so much!
Okay.
They say when you fail, get
on the horse and try again
or break the patient's ribs.
I think it needs to be all scalpel-driven.
Yeah, see, look at that.
Look at that.
Perfect cut.
You didn't even need to take out the ribs.
That's what rookies do.
See, look at that.
You see what I'm saying?
This is why you go to medical school.
You throw the intestines away.
You clear out the space that you need.
Whoa, chill!
Rectum.
Let's get rid of the liver here.
Okay, one kidney out, two kidneys out.
This is already looking more promising.
Kidney bean one, kidney bean two.
Okay.
Kidney one.
(Dr. Mike groaning)
Oh, wait.
Do you have to attach them or something?
No, no, no, they're in.
Oh, yeah.
Is that an A?
(audience cheering and clapping)
I can't really see, my vision's blurry.
I'm sure he'll live.
Brain surgery.
You know, when I was in med school,
that was the easiest type of surgery.
Patient's still Bob.
Bob, what kind of lifestyle are you living
that all your organs are failing?
Before you start any brain surgery,
you always have to start with a-
Oh, he's sitting.
Yo.
Oh.
What just happened?
Do I have to perform in the dark?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
So they made this-
Oh, there's the brain
that I'm gonna put in.
So to make the cut, I'm gonna need to...
But see, this isn't the
right tool for this job.
Where's my oscillating saw?
Here's my oscillating saw.
This is what you'd wanna use for this.
Yep.
Yep, yep, yep, just like that.
And you wanna get through,
gently breaking through
as if you're breaking
through a little egg.
I think I'm good.
Go ahead and put this down.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What is happening?
Do I have to cut it?
Oh, and it just fell!
Yo.
Oh, I dropped it.
Okay, but that's okay.
We can get this fresh one.
Go ahead and put this here.
Brain.
Slam dunk.
Let's go.
Let me see anyone try and top that.
I went to scratch my face
with the artificial hand
as if it's my hand.
Okay, let's begin the eyes.
Well, first things first,
you're gonna have to remove
the patient's goggles.
(playful music)
We need to take these out.
Oh, look, there's eyes in here.
It's so weird.
Do I have to cut off these goggles?
Oh.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that.
See?
Sir, can you tilt your
head just a little bit?
You're really gonna stay
in that direction, huh?
Oh, no.
I need you-
There you go.
Keep that eye open for me, would you?
I'm gonna need to gently.
Oh, dropped the scissors on your laps.
Sorry about that, sir.
Let's go with the, like, a
little sharp mini blade here.
Oh, I left this scalpel
inserted into your eye.
Okay, it looks like, I think,
I think I got it loose.
There you go.
Okay.
One eye out.
Sir, can you open up your other eye?
You wanna make a cut right
at the retinal artery here.
You wanna shake the person's
head, get the eye loose,
and then just make some
gentle cuts right at the eye.
Hanging, there we go.
Okay, and then basically what you wanna do
is you wanna empty out spare eyes here.
I'm assuming these are the right eyes.
So we're gonna go ahead
and pop those back in.
Let's get rid of the right eye.
Oh, actually that was the left eye.
I messed that up.
Okay.
Here we go.
Let's go ahead and pop that bad boy in.
What's up!
Aye!
(audience cheering and clapping)
Look at that.
You see that?
Those are the eyes I put in for you.
Pay me your copay.
I actually did a whole draw my life video
about my story coming to America.
Click here to check it out.
The animations are super fun.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)